gaming review of the 16 core m1 pro  macbook pro i have crossover 21 open you  have diablo 3 right here the lowest i  saw was 55 fps we have starcraft 2 man  it is stuttering such a massive  difference and now switching over to a  native game if you're playing world of  warcraft go for that 32 core now moving  on to some windows games gta 5 let's run  it man this is not running well look at  all that stuttering i definitely  recommend going for that 32 core m1 max  here we are in the dota 2 settings this  is the first game that i'm not seeing  that big of a difference for dota 2 the  16 core m1 pro is probably fine and our  next game is csgo so far this is  actually performing  really well guys we have minecraft  really well optimized if you are going  to be focusing on gaming definitely go  for that 32 core m1 max